yeah Jessica Pearson right now my good
gosh take me home let's see yeah I'm
pulling her up don't you worry about but
you got to like understand her role in
the show oh I know who this actress I
want to see oh I want to see some sexy
ladies just anybody in the comments
who's seen this the show
Suits her Jessica
[Music]
Pearson okay so we were just talking
offline about how a lot of the boys when
you guys are like on your Instagram
thing on your search page thing
Discovery page there's a hell of a lot
of titties and it's getting worse it's
getting worse it's not just girls in
bikini anymore for me it's girls like in
sexual positions yeah so you just keep
on clicking on all that stuff huh yeah
it makes me so mad it just shows up yeah
I get pissed off dud I get so mad I go
I'm just trying to be a faithful boy
that's what I say but my main anger is
is the jealousy see that they could post
all that stuff and not get taken down
yeah cuz you're trying to post stuff
like that too but you get if I drop a
little trout dude my my account gets
[__] yeah like one time like I had a
I was like I had a let dietrix like Moon
the camera once for like a split second
and I got it like a like taken down for
that like what what I got on probation
for [__] him being shirtless in a
photo yeah and my Ig stories how how do
all these girls but the thest thoughts
are thating all over and it's fine all
over all over the net the thti thoughts
are thating all over the place Ed gr and
po man on your Discovery page so today
we're talking about who is your favorite
influencer Crush who'd eat the [__] and
[__] I like how you read it like
somebody gave it to you like you didn't
make that no no no no that's I pulled it
off the internet influencer Crush I
pulled it off of like what's up good
prompt this guy smell [__] P you dollar
sign dollar sign why who is that for
that's for the editors they'll get a
little laugh that's how you spell it
though that's how you spell it so yeah
who would you want to who's your
favorite influencer You' want to eat the
[__] and fit an influencer and what's
the definition of an influence or
whatever like you know can it be like a
can it be like a fictional Persona in
like a TV drama sure go ahead tell us
who it is I have one right now that's
like my current life yes go go go go go
okay so I'm in I'm in a season of
rewatching suits is anybody seen suits
just started watching is good do you
like it um I haven't gotten fully into
it but I but I it's fun it's fun [__]
love it is it about a suit
store is it's it's a it's about a New
York law firm you're thinking of Men's
Warehouse
series that's what I was thinking about
all the drama so short synopsis like
basically there a guy his name is Mike
Ross he's like a delinquent if you will
and he has photographic memory so he was
able to [__] memorize like the entire
law book but he never went to law school
and he gets hired by like the top Law
Firm by this like super machismo guy
right and they are able to just sexily
[Music]
swaggishhooligan47 is it different I
want to see oh I want to see some sexy
ladies just anybody in the comments
who's seen this the show
Suits her Jessica Pearson if you don't
know then you don't know Joe oh it's
probably because of the character huh
it's kind of like like Cersei Lannister
that looks better than that picture cuz
like like who Cersei Lannister was in
Game of Thrones yes exactly versus you
see her in real life and Lena Haiti or
whatever you're like what the [__] she's
look I'm not necessarily like yo this is
the typee of woman I'm attracted to but
her character in the show I'm like
[__] cuff me yeah her character I'm
like you're in love with her constantly
blown away yeah okay what do you like
about her would she be like a she's so
boss like she like the the main
character Harvey Spectre he's obviously
like this dude who just like he's the
best closer in the city and lawyer [__]
is like you know you always like it's
always oneliner and you walk out cuz you
just shut the [__] down but he always
[__] gets shut down by her and that
makes you want to eat her [__] and [__]
who the [__] is your influencer dude
you're the last person that can judge
all right I'm bad yeah yeah dude I I
guarantee fans who watch the show and
understand and respect it they're going
to back me up fans don't think back them
up in the comments there's not many
[__] that fans think that Joe
wouldn't by the way just cuz of your own
stories Joe thinks [__] is [__] by
the way I just I'm just saying that I
don't I don't watch a TV show and go I
bet her [__] smells like licorice let
me eat it that's already a weird
reference licorice that Mak
I think it's like a charact he likes the
characters [__] not black licorice but
you told me yeah definitely Steve I'm
answering the question Joe just pick
somebody so that we can rag on tell you
told me okay who is the influencer you
would eat the [__] of yeah so
specifically I'm trying to look for one
who looks the most eatable and two
[__] when I watch TV shows unlike
this horny Savage Anthony
I don't think about having sex with the
characters what what TV shows do you
watch you probably watch Like You
watches
cartoons cartoons e he watches cartoons
yeah well that guy is kind of sexy but
you eat that scrum yeah I do cuz I'm
thinking if we're the only last two
remaining Souls on this Earth there's
going to be some kind of [__] going
on not that I want to but I don't know
just answer the the question all right
hold on let me find this I I'll give you
talk Talk Amongst yourselves yeah just
[__] this has been this has been
Joe's theme today
yeah Bart we and we can't say our own
wives obviously I don't want to eat a
puss the last person you want to [__]
suck
[Music]
on ew
gross you got anybody who would let me
see that's a hot kind of a really hard
question actually you're welcome for
going first then hey good for you way to
go I would say the
two hottest people that comes first to
my mind right now is Rihanna and then
Margot
Robbie strong well done
influencers Rihanna what I like is she
is boss in real life yeah is what I like
about her even seeing her like pregnant
pics like she carries herself like she's
a [__] queen of some country or some
[__] so it's pretty tight she did like
get an honorable something in Barbados
or whatever really yeah yeah like
recognized by like their royalty or some
[__] you remember that moment and this
is the end when um Michael Sarah smacks
her ass and she smacks the [__] out of
smacks apparently that she let him do it
as long as she she let him actually
smack her ass as long as she actually
got to hit him as hard as she wanted to
yeah that's dope yeah she's a gangster
okay this one this we're we're going to
[__] play this game okay we're going
to play we're going to play this game
what's the game Joe's taking it too far
I don't know where the names are I
follow these girls but I don't know
where the I don't know where the names
are are you on the right app of the
girls you
follow maybe this video is going to be
over by the time you're I'm going to
send you the accounts and you guys tell
me if this is proper if this is proper
Sweet Factory material okay d it's your
preference Factory that candy shop air
drop it to me what are you talking about
air drop it are we even answering the
same question anymore how do I air drop
it Joe's never answering the same
question dang Joe this is like a 14 GB
file can I just text it to you how about
Ry and a go first while the while we
work on the technology we're so close
and we're about to
end we can't leave everyone hanging
there waiting for this we won't okay
here's the first one is it can you show
it everybody yeah I'll show it to
everybody hold on and yes Margot Robbie
is chef's kiss okay he just texted to me
okay I got it I got it okay okay that's
Tanya Harding Penny Lane is her name her
name is Penny Lane Penny Lane Penny Lane
who's Penny Lane dude sounds like a
shopping store hold on it's loading Jus
Penny Lane sounds like a woman's
clothing oh wow Penny Lane what does she
do is she a model or influencers we're
looking for influencers we opened it up
but it's okay we opened it up you
guys character you do you do not have to
yell at anybody you can no because
you're breaking the rules okay Steve
specifically laid out I specifically as
if it could be a character thank you by
the way thank you I specifically asked
if it
be he's sticking up the Integrity of the
pr Joe's definition of integrity is
really off I'm trying to play with the
game and stay within the barometers of
the rules that's the first time you ever
done that all day Anthony is a rule
break rule B so you looked at her and
you go I bet her vagina is tasty yep and
not
ruined ruined wa this is PNY Lane just
walking around yep ruined by who she's a
model by other penises she's a model no
by AIDS or something oh
okay suppos said oh my I didn't know you
could tell if someone had AIDS from the
face yeah I don't know personality
mostly she doesn't looks like a she
doesn't look like a AIDs carrier to
me okay this P Lane I like Jo's answer
strong qualifier
e is he what do you do nothing I just
pulled up Penny Lane that's her name
show us freaking
hatere that's you doing that to God's
creature I'm not going to show I'm not
showing it let me see I'm not I'll show
it to you guys I'll show it to you guys
her name's Penny Lane this the first one
that came up we're not going to clown on
some lady named Penny Lane out there
some Librarian from [__] Timbuktu Tim
Buck two who's your influencer
I I have another one we got to keep
these short I have another one yeah yeah
let's see what ones you got that that
who's that just look at her ass what's
her name what's her name's her name
though always say it like that I can't
pronounce Veri Kamas Veri Kamas spend
the rest of the video saying I have
another one and showing us another one I
will not respect you as much yeah for
Nick D you're up okay I got to check
dude I don't know I don't have any just
pull up your activity feed you [__]
sick honestly all my activity Fe is like
dud how about anyone on your mind just
recently that like oh she's pretty
smoking that I would eat her out this
one just popped up on my feet a girl has
a butterfly on her ass tattooed don't
this one popped up on it just and then
they're they're they're trying to take
it out Joe's respecting The Prompt he's
now just ping like arbitrary ass he
doesn't even know who I know I know who
mine is now because this this uh woman
is like
insane she's crazy in the membrane I
don't know who she is but she just
popped up on my feet and it looks like
she's [__] forward and he would already
eat the [__] look at that yep look at
that what am I looking at oh it's bottom
up okay I respect his Integrity I do too
see and this is my feed if you want to
look at my feed you see it's just
[__] everywhere no hotties dude I
mean they're all [__] matcha yeah
girl lot of butt cheeks bro mug shot no
naughties mug shot
a girl with a CO a [__] Shadow on her
face dude here I'll show you cuz you'll
[__] agree with me she's Korean hey
why didn't you let me see
first you probably already have her
saved she's Korean and like just this is
her SK she plays piano oh wow is she
playing piano with a [__] not just that
like well no not that at all why the
[__] I think Ryan is a person of talents
type of guy but like look at this whole
thing it's just so admirable oh wow of
that dude look how high her skirt is she
was playing drums with her [__] she was
not playing drums she wasn't you guys
just so you know I saw it she wasn't her
name's like a yon a like a ye e o n
she's Korean she does piano drums and
different instruments and she can do
jazz so Talent turn Talent turns you on
just let you guys know talent doesn't
turn me on talent in that package is
just like such an anomaly that it it
just gets my attention I'm like wait why
is that she's probably on some podcast
somewhere else in the world saying this
about you my
God it's it's intriguing because like
when you look at her you're like you
could have just existed so untalented
and been fine but yet she has a talent
of like the ugliest person on Earth
really I want to see how ugly she is I
[__] with you Ron she's not ugly but
she's just like so good
yeah than I can't tell if her [__]
would be tasty from
here there's that integrity coming right
back into this video but before you guys
think I'm a pervert this is also on my
we've thought you per we already
you're this is also on my explor we
already think you're per it's okay Joe
golden retrievers with backpacks all
right okay real quick okay this is mine
real quick this is they call this the
hottest food truck lady she's like does
Thai street food and she Jiggles all
over the [__] place yep oh she knows
what she's doing huh that's definit yeah
she's really talented those like
does she make good food though nobody
cares the other cool thing okay but my
meme my meme one she's always been my
meme one
oh is this girl from this meme everyone
knows this
meme you guys are
perverted oh I love that meme explainer
meme that's always like a crypto meme
he's like hey let me tell you about this
crypto just going on right now she's
like oh my [__] god dude the way that
he's got her neck is so crazy
she is pretty hot though yeah I thought
that was Paris Hilton and who knows what
she actually looks like sometimes you
get people at the right angle whatever
whatever but yeah this I wish we could
know what he was really trying to tell
her dude know so fine probably
explaining the game of baseball to her
okay Nick you want to share yours now
real quick uh [__] dude I don't really
you had all the time all this time we
all have opened up and shared [__] I
saw the Barbie movie I liked it and so
I'll say Margot Robbie dude I'll say you
can't say someone El good Lord the most
under Welling well dude I don't I just
[__] I that's the last thing that's
fresh in my mind you're deflecting
aren't you no I'll gave you an answer
classic deflector where's where's your
integrity like Joe how about this look
at my your lady is like I for your
birthday I want you to smash one of
these celebrities you have to pick one
you have to if you don't she bring it up
with you who do you pick Hall Pass dude
I go back to my first my answer dude I
go you can't pick someone else's I just
[__] in her your turn but I love the
saloy
seconds um [__] I don't know dude who's
a [__] celebrity let me think no this
is going to be take too long dude we got
this is all Steve day we got to get to
the next one I gave you my answer dude
let's do an episode about just Nick
going who's a celebrity I'm trying I'm
trying to think of what that's like that
gets my rocks off I don't know f [__]
what's her name Rose Nama Unis n dude
figh way Le way Le D the Chinese MMA
fighter
Val
chenko uh she'd probably I don't like
girls that could kick my ass dude oh you
don't no I'm not into that you don't
like Ronda Rousy n I'm not I don't think
she's that fine to me she's not she
doesn't get she didn't get the Rocks off
how about this athlete yeah we'll go
with that the high jumpers yeah I like
high jumpers there's also that one is it
Argentinian volleyball
girl I don't know about that what about
the pole vter chick yeah can't miss you
can't miss with them I feel like their
their [__] probably tastes like sand
and that's the end of this video all
right see you guys
later you did it with class
bye-bye